when a soulless slap Dash and generally
sub-bar sequel follows the fan favorite
character's cinematic debut how's a
viewer not gonna feel betrayed turns out
sequels did more harm than good to these
big screen Heroes
remember with great power comes great
responsibility unfortunately writer
director Sam Raimi couldn't live up to
these words of wisdom when creating
Peter Parker for Spider-Man 3. the first
two movies of the trilogy established
Peter as a wimpy nerd who uses his
Newfound superhuman abilities to
selflessly fight crime after carrying
the burden of his Uncle Ben's
preventable death he's constantly
battling The Impossible Balancing Act of
living a normal life and fulfilling his
superhero duties in Spider-Man 3 though
his down-to-earth like ability is
replaced with arrogance and selfishness
and that's before the Symbiote gets a
hold of him the scene where Spider-Man
kisses Gwen Stacy in front of his
girlfriend Mary Jane at a festival
celebrating the greatness of Spider-Man
is an ample example of how far gone his
character is inflated ego and all it's
still hard to believe that it gets even
worse when Peter fully Embraces his
symbiote Alter Ego Peter's strutting
around town with his gelled emo styled
hair while shooting finger guns is
enough to make anyone's skin crawl of
course when you consider the symbi be
out this newfound confidence is
purposefully meant to be a far cry from
the Peter we've come to know still this
out of pocket characterization was
traumatizing enough to turn people off
from Toby Maguire's Peter Parker for
good so much so that perhaps it became
one of the reasons as to why a fourth
installment was canceled in favor of an
entire reboot good thing he saved some
face with his clever cameo in Spider-Man
no way home but even that's not enough
to burn well this from our Collective
memories
the rom-com queen herself L Woods from
Legally Blonde takes the dumb blonde
archetype and flips it on its head she's
an intelligent capable kind well-rounded
woman who excels at anything she puts
her mind to frequently overcoming
damaging preconceived judgments based on
her overly feminine appearance and
attitude for many she's an inspiring
representation of women in the workplace
her Story begins when she becomes
interested in studying law at Harvard in
an attempt to win back her boyfriend but
when she realizes her true worth it
becomes about proving herself to the
best of her abilities however this
Monumental character Arc is completely
disregarded in the sequel Legally Blonde
2 red white and blonde slipping into the
Trope she wants to find L becomes a
caricature of herself no longer is her
love of fashion in the color pink
celebrated as a way to subvert
expectations rather these qualities are
now heightened to a degree of mockery
while the original push boundaries and
started important conversations during
the peak era of rom-coms the sequel is a
blatant attempt at a grab leaving an
unsavory taste in the mouths of those
who once looked up to Elle you ready to
hit the ground running
are these not my comfortable heels oh
cute shoes thank you based on the Jane
Austen novel Pride and Prejudice the
rom-com Bridget Jones Diaries fondly
remembered as one of the more successful
modern interpretations of the novel
embodying The spinster Elizabeth Bennett
32 year old Bridget Jones is the classic
character in her own right she doesn't
fit the mold of a desirable Modern Woman
at least not according to 2000's rom-com
logic but she makes it her purpose to
change that only to learn she's perfect
the way she is her imperfect lifestyle
and fun-loving personality make her
relatable to the film's Every Woman
audience so in the sequel Bridget Jones
the Edge of Reason hit theaters in 2004
fans were undoubtedly excited to see
their favorite character back on the big
screen however what fans saw was not the
Bridget Jones they remembered
repackaging the love triangle and
miscommunication tropes of the first
film Bridget Jones the Edge of Reason
brings nothing new to the table and even
goes as far as to undermine its heroine
Bridget is no longer the relatable woman
we once knew her to be lacking emotional
depth and any semblance of what made her
likable in the first place instead of
laughing with her the cruel jokes and
misunderstanding of the character make
us reluctantly compelled to laugh at her
in a sad turn of events
Adventurer and professor of archeology
Indiana Indy Jones is a cultural icon
within cinematic history introduced in
Raiders of the Lost Ark India is tasked
with retrieving the Ark of the Covenant
before the Nazis can get to the artifact
first he is The Reincarnation of 1930s
film action heroes with a fallible
element that makes him more accessible
to audiences the next two films Indiana
Jones and the Temple of Doom and Indiana
Jones in the Last Crusade continue to
build upon the character while staying
true to creators George Lucas and Steven
Spielberg's original vision for the
franchise the fourth film however left
many fans unimpressed and dissatisfied
Indiana Jones and the kingdom of the
Crystal Skull was filmed a whole 19
years after the previous sequel you
might be sensing a trend here in terms
of awful sequels rather than time
healing all wounds it tends to create
ones that were never there in the first
place in all fairness Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull was a well-off trip down
memory lane but perhaps relying too much
on Nostalgia was the sequel's biggest
downfall lacking the magic of practical
effects captivating Act in heartfelt
emotion Kingdom of the Crystal Skull
leaves fans with the worst version of
this legendary character
the success of Disney's Pirates of the
Caribbean the Curse of the Black Pearl
was surprising to say the least based on
the last theme park ride Walt Disney
would ever oversee the probability of
the film drawing in a significant
audience was low Additionally the pirate
genre had already walked the blank at
the time but despite these obstacles The
Curse of the Black Pearl delivered an
adventurous fantasy that would go on to
spawn four sequels quickly Disney
discovered the Mass Appeal of the
character Captain Jack Sparrow and if
you'd be so kind to be much surprised if
you'd drop me off my initially a
supporting character his overwhelming
popularity inspired Disney to push him
as a main protagonist in The Following
movies however his quirky mannerisms and
eccentric personality wouldn't be enough
to save the character from his demise by
the fourth sequel Pirates of the
Caribbean Dead Men tell no Tales Jack's
absurdity had become overdone and
joyless there was a reason the character
worked so well in a supporting role as a
leading man not enough changes were made
to take the character seriously it was
clear the franchise had run its course
and for that the character suffered but
who knows what the future holds
following the dark ominous tone of Tim
Burton's Batman and Batman Returns
Warner Brothers felt pressure from
parents and toy companies to make the
Batman films more marketable for
children their solution was to replace
Burton with Joel Schumacher as director
for the next two films in the franchise
Batman Forever and Batman and Robin the
initial transition was met with mixed
reviews but when Batman and Robin came
around in 1997 everything went downhill
going from Burton's eeriness to
Schumacher's Camp Extravaganza audiences
experienced Whiplash from the dramatic
tonal shift The Dark Knight and angsty
intimidating hero who was once a force
to be reckoned with was now being
treated as a kid-friendly joke no one
went unscathed in the subsequent
backlash Schumacher who was reluctant to
do a sequel in the first place later
apologized for disappointing fans saying
after Batman and Robin I was scum it was
like I had murdered a baby George
Clooney who played the Caped Crusader
also admitted fault saying quote the
truth of the matter is I was bad in it
since then we've had many more
iterations of the hero making it easier
to appreciate how far the character has
come since those dismal days
the film that launched a multi-million
dollar franchise comprised of sequels
remakes and television reboots is loved
by audiences for its sincere message and
heartfelt story The Karate Kid follows
the mentor's ship between 17 year old
Daniel Larusso and karate master Mr
Miyagi by the end of the first film
Daniel learns lifelong lessons about
courage respect and hard work however
the Karate Kid 3 seemingly forgets every
one of those lessons while rehashing old
conflicts in this sequel Cobra Kai's
John crease teams up with old friend
Terry silver to seek revenge on Daniel
and Mr Miyagi surprisingly the Duo's
plans work as Daniel slowly comes to
resent Mr Miyagi after everything the
Sensei and a student have been through
it feels out of character for Daniel to
turn his back on Mr Miyagi so easily
actor Ralph Macchio has since expressed
grievances with the film's
interpretation of the character
revealing on the podcast sway I just
felt for the Larusso character he never
went forward it felt like we were
redoing the first movie in a cartoon
kind of sense without the heart and soul
luckily Netflix's Cobra Kai has
successfully tapped back into the
character's roots and taken him in a
direction that resonates with fans
[Laughter]
comedian and actor Eddie Murphy couldn't
catch a break in the early 90s after
declining box office success in an
attempt to turn his luck around a third
sequel to The acclaimed comedy action
film Beverly Hills Cop was decided upon
despite Murphy's previous comments
claiming the only reason to make a third
installment would be for the money that
sentiment proved true when the film only
worsened Murphy's critical reputation
Murphy's portrayal of Detroit cop Axel
Foley was once praised for his genuine
charm and comedic chops however for this
new sequel Murphy had other ideas on
which direction to take the character
opting for a more serious and mature
approach the fan favorite character was
now a depressing less funny version of
himself later Murphy came to his senses
and expressed his disappointment with
his performance in interviews such as
Playboy calling the entire project
garbage with the fourth installment on
its way to Netflix some fans May
hesitate to see how the character has
changed 30 years later
before John gaveled sin went on to
direct The Karate Kid Parts one through
three he teamed up with none other than
Sylvester Stallone to create the best
sports drama in the history of Cinema
earning himself an Academy Award for
best director for it Stallone took over
the next three sequels but after some
negative reception on both of their ends
Salon failing to find success outside of
his Rocky Roll and Hamilton bearing the
weight of The Karate Kid Part 3 the two
teamed back up to recreate the Glory
Days for Rocky 5. putting avalson back
in the director's chair however anyone
who's seen the movie or glanced at the
Rotten Tomatoes page will know their
hopes didn't go as planned supposedly
concluding the story of Rocky Balboa
Rocky 5 left many disappointed with
where Rocky ended up going from a down
on his luck Underdog to a national hero
back to nothing with financial troubles
and a brain injury that leaves them
unable to box wasn't exactly what others
had envisioned for Rocky's end in an
interview with Jonathan Ross Stallone
also agreed the character's Direction
was misguided rating the film 0 out of
10. luckily 20 years later Stallone
reprized the role in Rocky Balboa and
re-established the character for the
better
if you were a kid who grew up on Disney
movies from the 90s and 2000s you're
likely aware of the direct to video
sequel phenomenon that plagued so many
favorites their overall downgrade in
quality made them an Infamous part of
Disney's history but nothing is as bad
as the film that started it all Aladdin
sequel The Return of Jafar not only did
it ruin the leads Aladdin and Jasmine by
casting them aside in a haphazard story
but even more devastating was the
butchering of the most treasured
character Genie refusing to reprise his
role due to Disney disregarding his
wishes that the studio refrained from
using his voice and marketing campaigns
Robin Williams was replaced by the voice
of Homer Simpson Dan castellaneta to be
fair it didn't matter who the role went
to because no one could have lived up to
William's improvisational genius Ron
Clements who directed the original
summed it up best by telling Vanity Fair
Robin changed the way animated films
were perceived His Brilliant comedy
brought an adult appeal to animation
that was new at the time we wanted him
because we thought his talents could
bring something new and Innovative to
Disney animated features that could be
and entertaining and he sure did
made you look
[Music]
thank you